[Music]
Disney is dominating Hollywood right now
with pit after box-office hit after the
success of Black Panther the studio is
showing no signs of slowing down and
that should it be a surprise because the
studio owns the rights the Pixar
buddy of Marvel characters and also
Lucasfilm it includes the entire Star
Wars library
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a benders infinity war is the
culmination of ten years of Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies we're finally
going to see Iron Man team up with
Doctor Strange the Avengers meets the
guardians of galaxy as all the
superheroes team ups unite against
Thanos solo a Star Wars story is the
second Star Wars spin-off movie as you
can probably tell from the title it's
going to be about the early adventures
in Han Solo Alden Ehrenreich is stepping
in for Harrison Ford as Spock legendary
smuggler are very excited to see Donald
clobbers step in as Luciano plant oh how
are you
14 years later were finally getting a
sequel to be incredible
and most of the original cast is
returning along with original director
Bradford this time mr. incredible is
going to be staying at home watching the
kids all laugh the girl goes out and
plays truck
Paul Rudd is back his app man in ant-man
in the wasp but this time is not
fighting crime alone Evangeline Lilly is
going to be a sidekick
as the female superhero the wasps you'll
probably want to tune into this Marvel
movie though because it will be the
first Marvel movie released after
Avengers infinity Wars a live-action
Winnie the Pooh movie is coming this
summer called Christopher Robin this
time Winnie the Pooh and his friends are
going to be coming into the real world
to help Christopher Robin as he's down
on this walk the moment that you heard
Winnie the Pooh speak he should have got
immediately excited because Jim Cummings
the original voice of Winnie the food is
reprising his role who Christopher Robin
the Nutcracker in the flora realms looks
like a gritty reimagining of the popular
ballet starting to Garrett Knightley
Mackenzie Foy and Morgan Freeman we're
getting a wreck it Ralph sequel him and
vanellope von schweetz are heading into
the Internet where they're going to meet
nine of the original Disney Princesses
and if you make Christmas plans Mary
Poppins returns a sequel 54 years in the
making is coming to theaters Emily Blunt
will take over Juliana DS iconic role as
Mary Poppins and she'll be joined by
Hamilton
lin-manuel Miranda so at the least we
know we'll have good music with finally
getting their first female that Marvel
Cinematic Universe movie with Captain
Marvel Oscar winner brie Larson is going
to be stepping into the role as the
superhero Tim Burton is going to be
directing a live-action Dumbo the movie
will start on fowl Danny DeVito Michael
Keaton and Disney also does nature
documentaries and their next one is
going to be called penguins in 2019
we're getting a fourth Avengers movie
that is currently untitled originally
this was supposed to be a part two to
Avengers infinity war but that's not the
case anymore
we don't know much about this movie but
what we do know is that Thor's Chris
Hemsworth will be in this movie in some
way Guy Ritchie's directing a
live-action Aladdin and Disney has
announced the entire cap Egyptian
Canadian actor Menna Massoud will play
the street rat turned prince while
arrangers actress Naomi Scott is going
to star as Princess Jasmine Will Smith
is going to take over from Robin
Williams as the genie
twittery forest coming summer 2019 and
we've been waiting for this movie for a
long time Toy Story 4 is supposed to be
about a romance between woody and his
long-lost love Fokine a live-action Lion
King is coming in july 2019 and there's
so much to be excited about beyonce is
going to play the adult version of Nala
and then she's going to be joined by
Donald clubber as the adult Simba and if
you're not excited yet James Earl Jones
is going to be back as Mufasa it's
directed by Jon Favreau he directed the
live-action Jungle Book this Disney have
the next Harry Potter on his hand
it certainly hopes so Disney is adapting
the popular young adult Janice
experience Artemis Fowl the
highest-grossing animated movie of all
time
frozen is getting a sequel the whole
cast and even the songwriters are
returning for frozen to
dancing get excited for Star Wars
Episode nine at the year's end it will
be the final entry in the first new
trilogy the movie was originally going
to be directed by Colin Trevorrow but he
recently parted ways with Lucasfilm
don't be worried though because JJ
Abrams is stepping back into the
director's seat we feel like the final
movie is in pretty good hands
the last three entries of 2019 are a
little bit of a mystery the first is a
Disney movie on the future of aviation
there are also two untitled live-action
movies coming out after getting respects
several times they'll be getting a
live-action move on a lot of people are
really excited about this because of the
casting of the main actress Chinese
actress Bui EB yes Disney also owns the
rights to Indiana Jones so we'll be
getting a fifth movie in 2020 Harrison
Ford is supposed to return and hopefully
it will make us forget about Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull right now there's an
untitled Marvel movie set for the end of
the summer but we're pretty sure that
that's going to be guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 director James Caan has
already confirmed on Facebook that he'll
be back to write and directed people and
he also gave fans a little hint in 2017
that the next film in the franchise is
coming in about three years if you do
the math it all adds up there's a movie
set on the schedule for the end of May
we don't know what it is but there's
been a lot of speculation that we'll be
getting a standalone obi-wan Kenobi
movie
from now until 2023 things are kind of
all over the place there are a bunch of
movies that have either been announced
or recorded but they don't have release
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
plus the last Jedi director Rian Johnson
is getting his own Star Wars trilogy we
don't know what they'll be about but
we'll probably get at least one of them
in the next five years you don't know
what will be coming out but Disney asked
the following weekend's locked down
[Music]
now some of these dates may not be set
in stone but if you have a movie coming
out in the next five years maybe take
another weekend
[Music]
you
[Music]